i don't want to alarm the others but
we're not alone i can see someone
out there you again
oh seems we're searching for the same
thing but for different reasons
there's another monolith i need to
examine over yonder
but the danger is too great
you can't handle these creatures i
really find that hard to believe
i don't fear the creatures i
i fear what i would do to them what i
would unleash
but the monolith holds secrets perhaps
there is a way back
could you aid me in reaching it you will
be compensated
count me in
i can feel it just out of reach
clear the way what he said about
fearing what he'd unleash how long has
he been altered
the same happens to me maybe indulging
him
might get me some answers
the monolith i seek is in a hidden
chamber
accessible only the true children of
enoch
you have the fire of enoch flowing in
your blood find
the broken bridge the secret chamber
will be nearby
tell me the backs you had with you
where is the native now august
transformed into one of those ferals
attacked us and i
i didn't have a choice
none of them did did you know about the
packs
why they changed the obelisk outrider
find it whoa i don't know how i did that
but i made it work something got
activated on the other side of the
bridge
when i was right about you i didn't
actually believe it
but you really are one of us more than
you know
hurry now clear a path to the monolith
the end is near
i'll have to clear them
so
so
why do you care about the obelisk i care
about the knowledge it might bring me
knowledge of what lies beyond the
possible
mister i don't know what you're talking
about
then you're more fortunate than me
there's the monolith
stand back i can't foresee the reaction
what reaction
are you insane
would i know what if i was
yes finally
i know what i need to do
your compensation
you